Now, let's take it a step further and
produce a UML analysis model of those requirements.
In particular, let's come up with a particular class called
the account class and you can make some assumptions.
You can assume that all of the deposits and
withdrawals are made in amounts that are positive integer number of dollars.
And you also do not need to include an attribute for the current bank balance.
We will add that as a refinement later.
Recall that a class description UML has a rectangle with three boxes.
The top box is the name of the class.
Here we're going to call it account.
The middle box has any attributes of that class.
And here the attribute that makes sense is some history of
the users' transactions, the, the withdrawals and deposits.
I call that particular attribute transactions.
And I'm treating it as a sequence of integers,
because we already assume that all the.
wi, deposits and withdrawals within in integers.
The class also has three operations, corresponding to the requirements.
One is deposits that takes an integer value and doesn't return anything.
Second is a withdrawal which takes a.
Integer value and doesn't return anything.
And the third is the query asking for
the balance, which doesn't take any arguments but returns an integer value.